Today we've chosen a title for our talk
namely, "The Flood Returns."
I wonder what this title brings to your
mind?
Perhaps some of you will think back to
a few years ago, when National Geographic
once produced a well-known documentary
in English it was called Before the Flood
and in Chinese it was given the title
"Before the Flood Comes."
It, too, was all about paying attention to
climate change.
Now, today is not a movie-appreciation
session
but you can actually find that documentary
on YouTube if you'd like to watch it.
Choosing this title today is really quite
fitting.
Why is that? Because, as you know, just
two or three weeks ago
there was a climate summit held over in
the United Kingdom.
I imagine none of us went there to join
the demonstrations outside.
There was also a recent survey
which showed that three-quarters of all
young people
are absolutely filled with fear about the
future.
And the reason for that is climate change.
So many young people today
feel utterly lost about what lies ahead,
because the road before them seems so
uncertain.
The flood is coming.
I remember, back in 2009, there was a news
story
about the Indian Ocean island nation of
the Maldives.
Their cabinet held a meeting, and they
deliberately went down to the seabed to do
it
that's right, they put on diving gear and
held the entire cabinet meeting
underwater.
Why would they ever do that?
They wanted to draw the attention of the
whole world, the attention of the entire
international community.
Their message was: if we ignore climate
change and the sea keeps rising like this
then their whole country will one day end
up beneath the sea.
And over here, this is the Solomon Islands
the Solomon Islands, located in the
Pacific, in the South Pacific.
This clip comes from the current-affairs
programme 60 Minutes.
The programme interviewed one of the local
residents living there.
In the picture at the very top
what you are looking at
is this man
who, back when he was a child
would
often come here to play.
But now
this island is completely gone.
You can no longer see the island there at
all.
The sea keeps rising, and a great deal of
land has already been swallowed up.
And by the way, over on your
picture in the bottom-right corner
is also quite interesting.
Because as the sea rises
the plants that once grew there, since
seawater is salty
those plants begin to die off.
This is a point
that we'll come back to again a little
later.
As the sea slowly rises, more and more
land ends up submerged.
And you'll notice it isn't only the island
nations affected.
This here is Venice, in Italy.
Because the sea level keeps rising
in recent years it has again and again
suffered from flooding.
I wonder if you've ever heard of the
so-called "MOSE Project"?
They planned to build a whole set of
floodgates to hold back the seawater.
This was the flooding as it looked back in
2019.
That bridge in the background is really
quite famous.
If you've ever been to the Venetian hotel
there's a bridge just like it outside,
isn't there?
This spot here was originally a canal.
But the seawater came flooding in, all the
way up to
the shops and the pavements, and you can
see the boats sitting right here.
And it wasn't only 2019, it flooded all
over again in 2020.
In other words, in recent years it floods
over and over.
Here in New Zealand,
I don't know if you've followed this,
but up above you there's a country called
Indonesia,
and Indonesia's capital is Jakarta,
which recently announced it's moving the
capital.
Why is that?
Because Jakarta sits right by the sea,
and as the waters rise it floods
constantly;
every time it rains,
every time a storm blows in,
it floods.
The reason is that so many people there
pump up groundwater,
which has caused Jakarta's land to subside
and keep sinking;
add to that the rising sea,
and every year the flooding grows worse,
so they've decided to relocate to the
island of Kalimantan.
This is actually affecting many countries
and a great many people.
For example, over in Bangladesh
many people along the coast have already
moved away
to areas further north and further inland.
These people are what we call
climate refugees.
And it's all because the sea keeps on
rising.
But it isn't only the rising of the sea.
This scene here, if you follow the news,
you'll surely recognise.
This July, in Henan, in China
because of relentless torrential rain
you saw scenes exactly like this: the
tunnels flooded, and the casualties were
severe.
The picture in the lower left is the
subway line that was flooded that very day
and inside the subway carriages, the water
rose right up to people's chests.
So why does so much rain fall, and why
does it flood this badly?
It's because, as the climate warms and the
air heats up
the amount of moisture the air can hold
becomes much greater
and so these bouts of torrential rain,
these sudden cloudbursts
become extremely severe the moment they
hit.
In just a few hours you can get several
days' worth of rain
and in just a few days, a whole year's
worth of rain.
Do you recognise where this place is?
Probably not, I'd guess.
This, too, was in the month of July
but this one is over in New Zealand.
It rained, and after just a single weekend
this was the scene once the rain had
finally stopped.
So it isn't only China
and it isn't only the Northern Hemisphere
the Southern Hemisphere is exactly the
same.
Just a few days ago
if you follow the news, you'll know
Vancouver was hit by severe rainfall
which cut off all the transport links
between Vancouver and the surrounding
areas.
Because so many of the highways were
flooded
and many of the bridges
were simply washed away.
If you look over to the right
that there is the railway track
the railway line
and it, too, was destroyed.
And you'll find it isn't only cloudbursts
that cause this kind of damage.
In recent years, if you pay attention,
every time a storm comes you'll hear this
term, the "storm surge."
A storm surge means this: at the time when
a storm blows in
the eye of the storm is an area of low
pressure
which pulls the seawater upward.
So every time a storm hits, the tide rises
higher and higher.
And that is what we call a storm surge.
This was back in 2005, over in the United
States
the scene after the rising sea came and
struck New Orleans.
So it really doesn't matter what your
particular city happens to be like
even a country like the United States
you'll find it floods just the same.
As I mentioned just a moment ago
rising seawater causes the plants along
the coast to die.
In fact, people later studied why Katrina
caused such catastrophic flooding in New
Orleans.
On the one hand, of course, it was Katrina
itself
the winds were especially strong
and on top of that, some of the levees
broke.
But there was also one very important
reason, and it is this:
as the sea kept on rising
it killed off the plants in many of the
coastal marshlands
so that along the coastline
there was no longer any buffer zone left
to protect it.
So when the storm finally came
the winds, and the great sea waves
struck the city directly.
This here was
the situation with Katrina back in 2005.
And this is Hurricane Sandy, in 2012.
I don't know if you recognise where this
is, but this is New York.
right on the east coast of the United
States.
And it's worth pointing out that New York
actually lies at over 40 degrees north
latitude.
The word "hurricane" simply means a great
wind.
If it were in Hong Kong, we would call it
a "typhoon."
Its proper scientific name is actually the
"tropical cyclone."
that is to say, a cyclone of the tropics.
As the name itself suggests, these storms
all form in the tropical regions.
Yet New York sits at over forty degrees
north.
So you can see how global warming is now
driving many tropical disasters
such as storms striking far to the north,
and it seems to be becoming a new normal.
Likewise, if you've ever been to New York,
you'll know the lay of the land there.
The rising sea, together with the storm
surge
flooded Manhattan, specifically Lower
Manhattan.
You know, New York actually has a nickname
the "City that Never Sleeps."
Lower Manhattan is basically a financial
centre
lit up around the clock, twenty-four hours
a day
because of all of the
financial trading.
As it turns out, many financial
institutions keep their computers down
underground.
And that particular flood
caused very serious damage.
In fact, it took several years afterward
to slowly recover from it.
The subways were flooded in exactly the
same way
and swarms of rats came scurrying out
as if giving the whole city a thorough
washing.
In this picture on your right
it's hard to imagine a subway station,
usually so busy with people, completely
underwater.
You can see the divers there carrying out
the search and rescue.
This is Macau, back in 2017, struck by the
typhoon Hato.
Because of this storm surge, the seawater
came pouring back inland
leaving the whole city in this state.
And here, too, the casualties were severe.
I didn't actually put up any of the photos
from Hong Kong
but you'll notice that every single year
whenever a storm comes
in recent years, Hato in 2017, and
Mangkhut in 2018
you'll find the coastal areas, whether
it's Tseung Kwan O
or Heng Fa Chuen and other low-lying spots
the coastline gets battered by the waves
again and again.
And speaking of all this
I'm reminded of a verse in the Bible, in
Luke chapter 21.
The Bible describes the state of the world
before the Lord returns
and among those words is this one line:
on the earth distress of nations
in perplexity because of the roaring of
the sea and the waves.
The Bible also speaks about our last days
and one of the disasters it names seems to
be the very waves of the sea.
We've just been looking at this rising of
the sea,
at storm surges;
and in fact,
I first noticed this verse back in 2004
and that was because of the great South
Asian tsunami.
And of course there was also the tsunami
triggered by the great East Japan
earthquake in 2011.
These events all seem to be telling us
something
this very situation, that because of the
waves of the sea
people are gripped with fear and
confusion.
And this reminds me of something the Bible
records in particular.
When the Lord Jesus was on earth, He once
helped His disciples out on the Sea of
Galilee.
They suddenly ran into a fierce storm;
now, some of the disciples were fishermen
and had seen storms before
but the storm was so violent that they
even thought they were about to die.
Yet the Lord was there asleep in the
stern; they woke Him, crying out, "Lord,
we're perishing!"
The Lord got up, rebuked the wind and the
waves, and made the whole storm completely
calm.
I find this account recorded in the Bible
deeply meaningful.
On the one hand, you see the Lord Jesus
He truly is able to rescue us out of every
danger.
And on the other, it shows that the Lord
can calm any storm.
No matter what it is, in your own life
whatever hardship you happen to meet
whatever blows come, whatever storms arise
the Lord is able to calm every single
storm.
If a Christian friend has invited you here
today
the truth is,
your Christian friends would be very glad
to share with you how
the Lord has helped them calm the storms
in their own lives.
Alright, let me pose a question to
everyone.
In this glass here, it's filled up with
ice, and filled with water too, right up
to the very brim.
After a while,
once the ice has melted,
here is my question for you all:
will the water overflow the glass,
or will it not?
It won't.
It won't, will it? Very impressive indeed.
So what am I really getting at?
Water is a very special thing,
and not just in its structure,
because it is H₂O;
the H is hydrogen,
which,
as you know,
is itself flammable,
and the O is oxygen,
which itself supports combustion.
And yet, remarkably
hydrogen combined together with oxygen
becomes water, and water is able to put
out fire.
There's another special thing too:
everything expands with heat and contracts
with cold.
The lower the temperature falls, the more
the volume of water shrinks down.
But here is the strange part.
When it reaches 4 degrees Celsius
its volume
shrinks right down to its smallest point
and then it shrinks no further at all.
At 3 degrees, then 2, then 1, and at 0
degrees when it freezes, the volume
actually starts to expand.
And so its density, instead of rising,
decreases.
And because the density is now lower,
you'll notice the ice floats on top of the
water.
So you see, ice really is quite a special
thing.
And why is that? I believe it is the mercy
of God.
Just think about it, if water became
denser as it froze and sank down to the
bottom
then every single living creature in the
sea would die.
Just imagine it, it would be like a person
walking to the edge of a cliff, and the
moment they fall off, they're dead.
But you'll find it's a wonderful thing:
when water freezes,
its volume actually expands instead,
its density drops,
and so it floats on the water.
There's one more special thing too. What
is it? You can see the ice looks quite
large, can't you?
But when the ice turns back into water,
its volume actually shrinks;
because,
as I said,
freezing makes it bigger,
and turning back to water makes it smaller
again.
And the volume it loses is precisely the
part that had been sticking out above the
water.
So some people say, when you see an
iceberg, you'd better get well away from
it.
In fact, the part of an iceberg sticking
out above the surface is only about 11
percent.
The other 89 percent lies below the water.
So a full ninety percent of any iceberg
lies down beneath the surface.
So when you spot an iceberg from far away
the ice beneath the water may already be
very close to you, without your ever
knowing it.
Now,
ice that floats on the ocean,
up on the surface of the water,
doesn't actually cause the sea to rise;
it only leaves the polar bears with
nowhere to stand,
because as the ice melts they may have to
travel very far to find a foothold.
In other words, what really causes the sea
to rise
is mainly the ice sitting on the land.
And what do people usually mean by that?
They mean Greenland, and Antarctica.
Here's a news story for you.
Just this past August
you'd find it quite remarkable
it rained in Greenland for the very first
time.
At first I really didn't think much of it.
My immediate reaction was something like
this:
surely it must have rained in Greenland
before?
Why do you think this made it into the
headlines?
Well, just think about it: Greenland is to
the east of Canada, very far to the north.
It really shouldn't be raining there at
all, it should be snowing, do you see?
So the first recorded rainfall in
Greenland shows that the temperature has
genuinely risen.
And on your right, you can see those dogs
pulling along a sled
they're not walking on water; it's that
the surface layer of the ice
is melting very, very badly.
So when you photograph it from this angle
it looks as though the dogs
are walking right across the surface of
the water.
This is actually in Greenland
that is to say, Greenland
the melting of the surface ice there.
Someone has calculated that if all of
Greenland's ice were to melt
the sea would rise by around twenty-odd
feet, roughly two storeys high.
Two storeys
twenty-odd feet is really very high; I
wonder how close to the sea your homes
happen to be.
I wonder for all of you
which floor you live on.
But what if the water, the ice of
Antarctica, were to melt, what then?
Antarctica holds nine times as much ice as
Greenland does.
That means if the ice of Antarctica and
the ice of Greenland were to melt together
the world's sea level would rise up by
around 21 or 22 storeys.
Would you like to picture that scene for a
moment?
And this is only the rise caused by the
land ice melting.
In fact, when the temperature rises, there
is another factor, another influence, that
is very significant.
It's that, as the temperature climbs, the
seawater itself expands.
And this expansion of the sea, which
raises the sea level, is actually a very
serious matter.
This February there was a news story.
For the very first time, a Russian
icebreaker was able to cross
a passage in the Arctic Ocean that had
never once been navigable before.
So what does this actually tell us?
It tells us that in the Arctic Ocean, at
the North Pole
the ice has grown very much thinner.
Now you might well say
hold on a moment, you've only just
finished telling us
you said that at the North Pole
ice melting on the sea won't affect the
height of the water.
But here's the thing
there are still other effects.
In recent years, haven't you often been
hearing about heatwaves?
We went through one this June.
This June a heatwave struck Canada, and
Canada is very far to the north.
Vancouver sits at 50 degrees north
latitude.
But just think of Vancouver's
neighbour, the city of Calgary.
In Calgary
it reached over 40 degrees Celsius.
You might well find that very strange.
Why would there be a heatwave so far
north? If you look at the heatwaves of
recent years
they're often caused by one thing, what's
called a "heat dome."
In Chinese it's popularly known as a "heat
lid."
a lid, as in a covering lid.
Just imagine you're cooking something,
boiling some water.
With a lid on, or without a lid
isn't it different?
With the lid on, doesn't it come to a boil
much faster?
Because all of that steam simply can't
escape.
The steam can't get out
so it boils very quickly.
It's exactly the same principle at work.
Because in this picture, you can see
can you see, there's a jet stream right
here
that is, a high-speed air current, way up
high in the atmosphere.
It forms an area of high pressure
so that all the air trapped down beneath
it
even though it isn't hot in itself
simply cannot disperse.
It has no way at all to escape.
It's just like putting a lid on the pot.
So that within a very short span of time
all of that trapped air
heats up extremely fast.
So just think about it, at over 50 degrees
north
you can still record over 40 degrees
Celsius.
That really is quite staggering.
Alright.
But there's something I want you to
notice.
I'm not really here just to introduce the
heat dome.
Let me add one more term while we're at
it.
This kind of air-current phenomenon
is actually called an "Omega Block."
because its shape closely resembles the
Greek letter Omega.
What I really want you to notice is the
influence of the high-altitude jet stream.
You'll find that because of the way it
wanders
hot air gets trapped, and so you get heat
domes, and heatwaves.
And likewise, because of this very same
wandering
you'll see it drives the cold air out of
the Arctic
sending those polar vortexes down toward
the south
reaching much further south into some
regions.
So in recent years you constantly hear
news of
many places suffering from heatwaves
while at the very same time
many other places
are hitting record-breaking cold.
There was even a time
on one occasion
when Toronto
recorded a ground temperature colder than
the Arctic itself.
And why is that?
It's because of this very phenomenon.
You might want to ask a question here.
Why does this jet stream wander about like
this?
Well, the reason the jet stream wanders
is that it has grown weaker.
Because it has weakened, because it has
slowed right down.
Just imagine it, it's like a river.
when it reaches its lower course, when it
reaches the flat plains
doesn't it slow right down? Because the
slope is no longer as steep.
And in order to keep moving forward,
doesn't it begin to wind about?
That river starts to meander, doesn't it?
Well, it's exactly the same situation
here.
Because the jet stream
has weakened and slowed down
it begins to wander; and because of this
wandering
the heatwaves I spoke of earlier, and
those invasions of Arctic cold, are
becoming more and more frequent.
Alright, so now you'll ask a question: why
has it grown weaker?
Well, this actually proves one thing: that
the Arctic has warmed a great deal.
Because the difference between the
Arctic's temperature and that of the
surrounding regions
the greater that difference is, the faster
the surrounding air rushes in toward the
Arctic, and the stronger the jet stream
becomes.
But once the Arctic warms up, that
temperature gap shrinks, and so this jet
stream grows weaker.
In fact,
research shows that global temperature
change isn't uniform at all,
and in the Arctic the temperature is
rising four times faster than in the
surrounding regions.
In other words, the Arctic region is
warming up far more quickly.
You might want to ask a question, namely:
why is it warming so very fast?
One of the main reasons is the great
Siberian wildfires.
This fire has actually been burning for
several years now; and in fact, the
largest fire of the entire 21st century
is the great blaze burning this year in
Siberia, in Russia.
The area of this one fire, compared with
North America's
the wildfires of California and Canada put
together
add to that the fires of Europe, and of
Turkey, and this one is still larger in
area.
This was captured from high up above
the situation of the Siberian fires; and
you'll notice, aren't there many spots
where there's no smoke at all?
Why is it so strange? Why can I see only
smoke, and no actual flames?
It turns out the fires in Siberia, within
the Arctic Circle, are very peculiar
indeed.
This kind of fire has a name: it's called
a "zombie fire." And as the name suggests,
do you know what it means?
You can't smother it, and you can't put it
out.
Why is that? Because inside the Arctic
Circle it's so cold
that after many of the plants die
they don't decompose.
So beneath the soil there's a great deal
of organic matter.
And when a fire breaks out, sometimes
these flames
will burn their way down underground.
And once they've burned down underground
you'll find that
you simply cannot put them out.
But given the chance, they'll burn their
way back up again
to the surface.
So this fire has, in fact, been burning
for several years now.
Does it have any consequences?
This here is the ground, captured in
satellite imagery.
You can see all those points of fire,
can't you?
Underground, it's still burning away.
But the moment it gets a chance, it breaks
right out to the surface.
The whole landscape smoking over, that's
exactly what's happening here.
You might ask, the great Siberian fires
these Arctic Circle fires, what impact do
they really have?
Last year there was a news story just like
this.
You see the picture at the top, that
river, has it not turned completely red?
And it's not because of any blood.
It's rather because of
an oil spill.
You see, the ground in the Arctic Circle
is called permafrost, ground that has
built up a great deal of ice and frozen
solid.
And on top of it sit many oil refineries,
and many storage tanks.
But as the Arctic Circle warms and this
ice melts away
many of these facilities, the storage
tanks for instance, subside, and start
leaking oil.
This was the spill back in May of last
year, and it was a genuine ecological
disaster.
If you go to Siberia these days, you'll
often see craters just like these.
Looking at the people standing beside
them, you can grasp just how huge these
craters are.
So why are there such enormous craters?
Who would have the time to dig such holes?
In fact, they weren't dug out at all.
It's because the permafrost has warmed up
and the ice has melted
releasing the methane that had been
trapped down in the ground.
And this methane
here you can see
it's rather like a bubble.
That is, down beneath the soil
beneath all that vegetation
there's a pocket of methane gas.
And sometimes it simply explodes
which created those very craters you saw a
moment ago.
And those bubbles down beneath the water's
surface
are all of them methane.
If you go and find some of the photos
online
there are people playing around with it
right there on the ice
they bore a hole into it, and then set it
alight.
Now this methane
as a greenhouse gas
methane's effect is actually 20 times
greater than that of carbon dioxide.
In other words, take a given volume of
carbon dioxide and its effect on
temperature
swap it out for methane, and its effect is
a full twenty times as strong.
So someone has actually studied this
and what did he say?
He said that once Siberia's methane is
released
the impact would equal that of all the
world's carbon dioxide emissions combined.
That is an enormous crisis indeed.
This also brings to my mind, in the Bible
another verse.
In the Book of Revelation, speaking of the
days of disaster still to come
an angel pours out his bowl upon the sun
and the sun is given power to scorch
people with fire.
Already, some places are hitting over 40
degrees; I mentioned Vancouver just now
and Calgary.
And some places have even reached over 50
degrees.
As I was saying, if this methane were to
be released in that way
then for the temperature of the whole
planet
the effect could come on very quickly
very abruptly indeed.
So if you were to ask me
this idea of the sun scorching people
I don't think it is
some far-fetched fairy tale at all.
In fact, there are already signs now
showing us
that this global warming
can indeed
turn very fast
and grow very severe.
In this picture here, it lets us see
the situation of the great forest fires.
We've already talked about the Siberian
blaze.
You can see it right here.
And here you can also see several more
fires.
This one here is the Amazon rainforest.
This one is the Congo Basin, in Africa.
And this one is Borneo, in Indonesia.
All of them are tropical regions
all of them are tropical rainforests
rainforest zones
and all of them are burning very severely.
We've already spoken about the Siberian
fire.
But what about the Amazon rainforest?
In fact, many of the Amazon fires are
deliberately set by people.
Some of them are for felling the trees, to
take the timber.
But more often, they burn down the forest
afterward in order to raise cattle.
And why is that?
Because the market price of cattle, the
value of the cattle, is high.
They can be sold off for a good deal more
money.
So you'll notice that one of the themes at
the climate summit
was to offer subsidies to certain
countries
countries such as Brazil, for example
so that it would ban people from clearing
the Amazon rainforest.
But the truth is
I'm not sure whether by now it might
already be a little too late.
And why is that?
In recent years many studies
have shown the Amazon to be the world's
very largest
tropical rainforest zone
you could even call it the earth's first
lung.
But here's the thing
some studies show
that the Amazon's carbon emissions
have now surpassed its carbon absorption.
Generally speaking
a rainforest,
when there's sunlight and photosynthesis,
draws in the carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and turns it into the carbon of
its trees;
and that is what we call carbon
absorption.
But why are the emissions now greater?
Well, for one thing, when it catches fire,
doesn't it release enormous amounts of
carbon dioxide?
And it also emits a great many carbon
particulates.
The trend over these last few years is
that
the Amazon's carbon emissions have already
exceeded its carbon absorption.
And it makes me think, these days, isn't
there always this coronavirus around? And
the problem it causes is pneumonia.
Pneumonia means you can't breathe; it's as
if the earth itself has come down with
pneumonia.
Then there's also the Congo Basin in
Africa that I mentioned earlier.
This one you could call the world's second
lung
and it, too, is a tropical rainforest
zone.
In the two photos over on your right
you can see that the firefighting
equipment there is really quite primitive.
How do you even fight a great fire like
this?
Just with those things, spraying a little
here, a little there.
Like a water pistol, how could that ever
put it out?
But how did these fires actually start?
In fact, they were set deliberately by
people.
Because over in Africa
in order to get food, you have to farm
and how do they go about farming?
They use a method that's called
"slash-and-burn."
That is to say, they burn down a patch of
forest
and that gives them a clearing to work
with.
The dead leaves even act like a fertiliser
to help the crops along.
And then they plant their crops right
there.
And after they've farmed it for a few
years
that ground becomes overrun with a great
many weeds
so the people move off elsewhere, and burn
down yet another patch.
And the plot they'd farmed first
is simply left
to slowly recover, and grow all its plants
back again.
This is actually how it has always worked,
all along.
This slash-and-burn method of working
is called "slash-and-burn cultivation."
So why has it now spiralled so completely
out of control?
This actually leads us on to another
problem.
Because there are more people now.
Because the population has grown so much
those abandoned plots have no time
not enough time left to recover.
Because there are so many more mouths to
feed
they have no choice but to keep on burning
and so the forests are given no time at
all to recover.
And so the world's second lung has come
down with pneumonia as well.
And this brings us on to the second
problem.
And it's that over these last hundred
years or so
the world's population has grown at a
breakneck speed.
As you can see here from this chart
in 1930 the whole world had 2 billion
people.
But by this year, and it's already late
November now
the global population has reached 7.9
billion.
According to the projections, in spite of
the pandemic
by the end of next year, perhaps
the world's population will break right
past 8 billion.
That is to say, going from 2 billion
all the way to 8 billion
in less than a hundred years, all told.
This is a very serious problem indeed.
Because when the population grows so large
the earth's resources are limited.
And which regions are seeing the
population grow most explosively?
It's in Africa.
So some people have even estimated
that within a few years
the world's largest city will not be New
York,
nor will it be Tokyo,
but a place in Nigeria called Lagos.
Africa is where the population is growing
the fastest, and then there's the Middle
East region too.
And there's India as well, of course; and
China's 1.3 billion are actually ageing
very rapidly indeed.
That's why in recent years they've relaxed
the one-child policy, encouraging, even
urging people to have two or three
children.
When there are so very many people, some
things simply can't be helped.
So you'll notice that the climate summit
didn't even touch upon this issue.
Instead,
it leaned entirely on the carbon-emitting
nations;
the biggest emitter of all is China,
and the second is India
both of them countries with well over a
billion people.
But you know full well that these promises
are only words on paper.
Why is that? Because just last month, for
instance
you saw China facing a power shortage up
in the northeast, didn't you?
Winter comes around once again, and once
again there's no electricity.
And no one even knows where that heating
is supposed to come from, or how.
And in China, the power is very often
generated by burning coal.
The population is enormous, and there's a
power crunch on top of it.
Not to mention that all of that
manufacturing needs electricity too.
And the power comes mainly from the
burning of coal.
So how can it possibly promise to cut its
emissions?
So really
this is a very big problem indeed; and in
the picture on the right
many people are now concerned with what's
called the earth's carrying capacity.
That is to say, just how many people can
the earth
with its land area, and its resources,
actually manage to support?
Over these past few decades many people
have studied this
and most scientists share one consensus,
which is this: that the world's
resources can supply around 8 billion
people.
But don't forget, with all of these
natural disasters and this shifting
climate
and I haven't even mentioned drought today
you can imagine that the earth is really a
kind of balance.
When some places are being drenched with
such heavy rain
then you can well imagine that other
places are suffering the most extreme
drought.
California is one such example.
And these disasters, at the very same
time, lower the earth's carrying capacity.
So really, this is a problem that no one
even knows how to solve.
And so, speaking of all this, I'm reminded
of a certain ship, the Titanic; the
Titanic sank because it struck an iceberg.
The story goes that at the moment it hit
the iceberg,
the captain immediately called a meeting,
and because the ship's designer happened
to be aboard,
and the owner too,
they all gathered together
and after inspecting it,
they discovered that at the bow,
the first,
the second,
the third,
the fourth,
and the fifth compartment,
that is,
the ship's holds,
were all taking on water.
And that designer grew very anxious indeed
because he was the one who had designed
the ship.
So the captain asked
this water coming in, can it be pumped
back out with the pumps?
Everyone looked at one another, and they
already knew exactly what was about to
happen.
Pumping out the water could only buy them
time
just a few minutes, that's all.
And why was that?
Because this ship
with three compartments, or four, flooded,
could still stay afloat
but with five compartments gone, there was
no way it could stay up.
So the ship's owner asked
the owner said, how can this possibly be?
This is her maiden voyage, her very first
one.
And that designer answered him
this ship is made of steel
and she will sink.
It's just a mathematical certainty
that is to say, it is a mathematical
inevitability.
And when you look at everything we've just
seen
it really is a very hard thing to face.
It reminds me of a few years back,
when Al Gore,
after he'd left office as the US Vice
President,
turned his attention to global climate
change
and made a film, called An Inconvenient
Truth.
What was the Hong Kong Chinese title
again? "The Truth of Despair."
And I feel that, up to this point, there
really is no hope at all.
Perhaps you'll say, the whole world can
join hands and cut its carbon emissions.
But as I mentioned earlier, at the very
least it overlooks one enormous problem
and that is the problem of population.
And getting the nations to take turns
cutting emissions together is itself
another problem.
So this is exactly why seventy percent of
young people
have so little hope for what lies ahead
and are utterly filled with fear.
And thinking it all over, I feel
that if there really were no hope at all
I honestly wouldn't know what on earth to
share with you.
But here is something precious.
At its very end, the Bible leaves us with
this one saying
and it's spoken by the Lord Jesus Himself.
The Lord Jesus, He sent His angel
to testify these things to the churches,
and what did He say?
There's a line that follows; what is it
that He says?
He says: I am the bright morning star.
You see, the deeper the night grows, the
darker and the colder it becomes.
And at the coldest hour of all, just
before the dawn
the morning star appears.
And when people see the morning star, they
know the dawn is very near.
So what does the Lord mean by this?
He means to give people hope.
That when you see Him
the dawn is close at hand.
And why is that?
Because the Lord Jesus has already
promised to prepare a place for us.
And once He has prepared that place, He
will come again to receive all who believe
unto Himself.
So the state of this whole world
is really meant to prepare people's hearts
to let people know
that in the world there is no hope.
But how precious it is
that those who have the Lord Jesus
they have a living hope, which is that the
Lord Jesus is coming back
to receive us unto Himself.
And now, I'd like to share a hymn with you
all.
This hymn is called "The Lord, Like the
Bright Morning Star."
It brings to us hope, it brings to us
light
so that even in our despair we can still
see the way out, far in the distance.